lors des célèbres monuments espagnol ces
jours ci envolées les milliards d'euros
que dépenser des millions de visiteurs
étrangers
autant dire que les barcelonais ont leur
célèbre rambla pour eux tout seuls mais
les terrasses est vide ce qui ne fait
pas la fête
ce qui est ce qu'ils adorent tout est
fermé et lança augustine castro du
jamais vu pour l'homme qui travaille ici
depuis plus de 30 ans il affirme que ses
ventes ont diminué de 95% que ce n'est
plus rentable surtout avec les impôts et
à l'électricité à payer hippiques le
gouvernement ne les aident les revenus
sont si maigres qu'il ne suffisent plus
pour payer l'éclairage le soir au
kiosque qui ne fermaient jamais n'est
plus ouvert que six heures par jour des
quartiers qui normalement devrait être
bondé de visiteurs de touristes sont
plutôt vide
si vous prenez le temps de regarder les
boutiques il y en a énormément qui sont
fermés les locaux font elles rue selon
des chiffres officiels à barcelone un
petit entrepreneur sur cinq a fermé
boutique dans la pandémie un peu partout
des locaux attendent des repreneurs à
tort à augustine castro et sa famille y
parviennent toujours à joindre les deux
bouts
mais c'est plus compliqué pour certains
de ses amis dont un couple de
restaurateurs ils n'obtiennent pas là
ceci n'aurait plus rien pour vivre et
serait prise à la gorge
il parle d'un grand drame humain
je n'ai plus démunis ont été les
premiers touchés
en 2020 les demandes dead dans les
banques alimentaires du pays ont
augmenté de plus de 60% ces jours ci
près de deux millions d'espagnols en ont
besoin dans ce quartier populaire de
barcelone on se dit d'abord que chaque
semaine au moins quinze nouvelles
familles réclament l'aide de la
fondation in délit son président demande
au gouvernement de bonifier l'aide
financière au risque de voir gonfler les
rangs des plus au nord une crise énorme
c'est plus important que lors de la
récession de 2007 2008
c'est à la fois une crise économique une
crise sanitaire une crise sociale
je dirais même que c'est une urgence
sociale urgence cette mère de famille la
vie au quotidien est un chouïa trace à
la noyade grâce à des leds s'accumulent
depuis qu'elle et son époux ont perdu
leur emploi
pour moi ça me paraît comme aucun de
nous ne travaille on accumule les
retards dans les paiements
ça nous cause des problèmes le couple a
quatre enfants à nourrir
et s'ils ne sont pas à la rue c'est
uniquement grâce à la générosité du
propriétaire de leur appartement
cette famille les banques alimentaires
sont donc davantage
je tente de trouver du travail mais
beaucoup d'entreprises ne tourne pas
bien des bureaux sont fermés
c'est là que je pourrais trouver du
travail et l'impression que la crise est
pire ces temps si difficiles toute la
ville semble espérer le retour des
touristes tout un contraste avec la
banque au vide alors que bien des
résidents se plaignait d'être envahi par
les visiteurs